okay so everyone's saying that they ate
the cookie what's your favorite dessert
boba boba why'd you eat the cookie
because I like cookies how was it the
cookie yeah delicious what's your
favorite dessert can I say Mama's
chocolate chip cookies I'm like that uh
what's your favorite dessert Tiramisu
cookies sorry Tiramisu and Milano cookie
oh okay you said you're in social media
here yes how are the videos with me
doing pretty bad that's a lie what's
your favorite baked treat
I don't believe that he thinks that he's
got me I think we've all got here I know
how was the cookie it was pretty good
not as good as a fresh baked cookie
that's actually a pretty good way to
describe a Milano they're a little too
crunchy favorite ice cream flavor
cookies and cream ooh cookie dough
actually cookie dough
cookies yeah
oh I should have looked at this first
what a weird bite that got taken out of
this